unbiased news is a myth ground news is a
news comparison platform that empowers
you to see how the political biases of
different sources are influencing the
news you read
download the ground news app for free at
davidpakman.comground
so yesterday was the first day of the
second impeachment trial of donald trump
and
we we had some hints that it was going
to be
an absolutely embarrassing pathetic
attempt at an impeachment defense
and one of the reasons we thought that
was that multiple times
in legal briefs submitted by donald
trump's various beleaguered
legal teams they misspelled united
states they misspelled it as united
states and that probably was not
the auspicious start that they were
going for and it ended up being an
absolutely
farcical presentation yesterday was a
day
it it was day one but at the same time
it wasn't in the sense that the topic of
four hours of debate
yesterday uh four hours of presentations
rather there was not debate among
senators
the topic the reason for yesterday's
four hours of presentations was
merely to convince the senate one way or
the other
about whether the senate has the
authority
and the jurisdiction to hold an
impeachment trial of
a president that is no longer president
a former president a past
president and why you would have the
senate decide about constitutionality
i don't know and uh many legal scholars
were not clear as to why the senate was
being put in the position
of having to decide whether it was
constitutional but
that's what yesterday was about the
senate decided not by a huge margin
56 to 44 that yes
the senate can hold an impeachment trial
of a president who is no longer
the sitting president democratic
congressman jamie raskin
opened the proceedings as one of the
impeachment managers
he spoke really well included in his
presentation an absolutely devastating
video of what happened on january 6th
cutting back and forth from what donald
trump was saying and what was happening
at the capitol
and then it was the turn uh
it was trump's lawyer's turn and a guy
named bruce castor spoke
we covered it live and he droned on for
about
50 minutes about nothing germaine to the
impeachment of donald trump now you
might say well that must be an
exaggeration david it must have been
somewhat related to the impeachment
i couldn't figure out how our live
audience of about 40 000 people couldn't
figure out how it was related
bruce castor going on about british law
before the revolutionary war
his personal relationships with some of
the senators in the
in the chamber um it's absurd
it's unintelligible let's look at some
clips here is bruce castor starting with
his own childhood
and uh the political preferences of his
parents
when i was growing up in uh suburban
philadelphia
my parents were big fans of senator
everett dirksen from
illinois and senator dirksen
recorded a series of lectures that my
parents had on a record
and we still know what records are right
on the thing you put the needle down on
and you play it so
that type of stuff went on about 10
minutes
then castor started talking about how
cool
and great senators are as individuals
and how senators tend to like the states
that they are from
their families they love the states
that they represent there
isn't a member in this room who has not
used the term i represent the great
state of
fill in the blank why because they're
all great yeah
but you think yours is greater than
others because
these are your people these are the
people that
sent you here to do their
work it genuinely seemed like maybe
bruce castor
prepared for some other trial about
something
different than the impeachment of donald
trump because
none of what he said made any sense it
became like an open mic
night which then continued with more
discussion
of what it means to be in the united
states senate as far as
bruce castor was concerned so senators
are patriots
senators are family men and women
they're fierce advocates for the great
state in which they represent
and somewhere far down that list of
attributes
way below patriot and way below love of
family and country and way below
fierce advocates for their states far
down
at least that's what i thought anyway
and i still think that somewhere far
down that list
senators have some obligation to be
partisans
if you're wondering what on earth he's
talking about
did you miss something we were all
wondering that yesterday
we it made no sense whatsoever i had no
idea what this guy was talking about and
indeed
donald trump was not happy we'll talk
more about this later in the show but
here's a report
from cnn about just how displeased and
rightly so
how displeased trump was with this not
think that was a strong opening argument
and then to have
the first attorney admit that he
believed the house impeachment managers
did a good job also it was confusing to
a lot of people on the president's team
but yes
trump was not happy with that
performance he was borderline screaming
over what was going on as he was talking
to people
about this it wasn't just donald trump
who was not pleased with what bruce
castor did
uh fox news host sean hannity himself
couldn't even resist
mentioning multiple times that it was a
meandering presentation that hannity
didn't really understand here he is
saying it to republican senator ted cruz
active i thought it was a little bit of
a weak
start i'm not being critical just a
little lackluster meandering to me
needed a little more focus needs focus
meandering quite and quite an
understatement if you saw the 50 minutes
of atrocities
from bruce castor there and then this is
even better when interviewing donald
trump's other lawyer david shone
again hannity says he he didn't really
understand
that first part your arguments i loved
your passion i thought it started a
little meandering
it was sort of like a lot of free
associating in the beginning and i'm not
i'm
i'm not attacking your partner i don't i
don't know him at all
so even sean hannity has to concede
in his own words in his own understated
way
this was absolutely off the wall
bonkers and it was also even some
republican senators that noticed this
here is republican senator
bill cassidy saying i didn't know what
he was talking about
i if if i just have to vote based on
what i see there
they didn't make the case trump's
lawyers for anything
we listen to it it speaks for itself it
was disorganized random
had nothing they talked about many
things but they didn't talk about the
issue at hand
and so if i if you if i'm an impartial
juror
and i'm trying to make a decision based
upon
the facts as presented on this issue
then the house managers did a much
better job
it was really like a verbal
inkblot free association a kind of um
senatorial rorschach test of sorts what
do you
here's 50 minutes of words mostly words
what do you make what can you make out
of them what do you see in there and
even many republican senators saying i
can't see anything in there that doesn't
make any sense
as uh as i was watching it our
with our audience on the live stream
yesterday i was saying does trump fire
this guy
by today as of yet he has not been fired
but later on in the show we are going to
have a report about
what what exactly was going on with
donald trump including apparently
screaming
as bruce castor was making his
presentation we'll see if day two
goes any better for trump's legal team
that's coming up a little bit later
today
okay we are continuing to learn
about who the individuals
involved in the january 6th trump riot
are
and who they were and what areas of
society and industry they came from
now i already told you it was either
last week or maybe the week before
that members of the military current and
former
uh were dramatically overrepresented
among the trump rioters on january 6th
something like
14 of those arrested uh
were either former or current members of
the military that's very concerning and
we now have another
individual story 14 is is a a general
number
we now have an individual story that's
even more horrifying
according to time a man who authorities
say
is a leader of the far right oath
keepers militia group
and helped to organize other extremists
in their participation in the january
sixth trump riots
number one held a top secret security
clearance for decades
and number two previously worked for the
fbi according to his own attorney now
you might be wondering
why is this guy's own attorney saying
these things it
it raises more concerns it should make
us horrified that that was the position
this guy held
well his attorney is raising these
issues to justify
that he should be out on bail and that
he's super trustworthy and you don't
have to worry
about him the man's name is thomas
caldwell authorities believe that he has
a leadership role
in this extremist group called the oath
keepers he was fbi
section chief between 2009 and 2010.
this is not any fbi person would be
a real red flag in terms of their
participation but this was not
a nobody to the extent that there are
nobodies in the fbi
this was a section chief from 2009 to
2010.
previously he was in the navy again we
talked about the over-representation of
members of the military among the trump
rioters
and his lawyer thomas ploffshin
wrote in a motion saying listen look at
this guy's creds
you can safely release him as he awaits
trial
because he was in the navy and he was
fbi section chief and
the reason why you can trust him
is he had this top secret security
clearance and he worked for the fbi
and he had a consulting firm that did
work for the us government this guy's
trustworthy
and of course as many of us learn more
and more about the individuals
involved in the january 6 riot we are
horrified we are horrified about wow i
mean listen people can change in 11
years
right this guy was fbi section chief
from 2009 to 2010
in 2021 he finds himself uh
participating
in the trump riot um many of us would
logically be led to ask did the fbi
miss signs about this guy back
in 2009 and the counter argument will be
well no the fbi could have done its job
at vetting in 2009 there really might
have been nothing there then
and something happened since then that
ended up radicalizing this guy to the
point where
he's part of the oath keepers this
right-wing militia group and he's
participating in the january six riots
but
we all should be asking um who else is
in there now
who who's in the military now who's in
the fbi now
that has these same ideas the same
ideology the same uh allegiances for
lack of a better term as this guy and
we just don't know about that yet that
is a very very uh
concerning element of this and the truth
is we should be horrified
that uh these are the individuals that
not just participated but allegedly
were organizers of the trump riot this
is essentially a terrorist this is
someone who
organized others to attempt
a violent insurrection because they
didn't like
the results of a democratically held
election there's really no other way to
define
what these folks are and um the
the other kind of a few people wrote to
me and they said you know it's
interesting that
this guy caldwell is now uh he's he's
disabled legally
he uh is on disability and he's received
he's on the government dole so to speak
and uh pointing out people
were pointing out two things one is less
interesting to me some folks wrote to me
and said david this guy
clearly is not disabled because he was
able
to participate in the riots i think that
that's the wrong
angle to go at i think it starts to get
into these sometimes prejudicial or
discriminatory things about
what is a disabled person look like and
i don't like that i'm not going to go in
that direction
the part that is more interesting from a
political standpoint is that a lot of
anti-government extremists
are sometimes completely dependent on
the government and
that reminds me of you know keep the
government out of my medicare
sort of stuff where do people not
understand where their
benefits are coming from or do they not
care
are they blinded by ideology is it some
combination of all of all of the above
that's more interesting to me
evaluating whether someone is or isn't
truly disabled based on whether they're
at the riot i'm not going to get
involved in that
but the numbers continue to be
concerning 14 of those arrested
former or current military we now are
learning more about individuals who were
relatively high ranking folks within
agencies up to and including the fbi
this should horrify
all of us we know that the military has
been looking at white supremacy within
its ranks for some time
but what is the fbi doing what is the
cia doing how many of these folks
are in there within the system and what
does that mean
going forward when we think about
federal responses to events like this
which
hopefully will be very infrequent but
but history tells us
uh it is bound to happen again at some
point and how how prepared will we
actually be
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter at deepakman we'll be back
and much to discuss today the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
the riots at the capitol made it very
clear that misinformation is one of the
biggest
problems that our society faces and
online filter bubbles make the problem
worse
making it difficult even for intelligent
news consumers to figure out what's true
and what's not
one of our sponsors is ground news which
is a platform with a really effective
approach
to combating this problem ground news is
the world's first
news comparison platform that lets you
compare
how sources from across the political
spectrum are covering a story
i use it myself i love it because it
lets me easily see how different news
outlets are manipulating a story to fit
their own narrative
and it shows you your news blind spots
stories that your side of the political
spectrum
may not be giving attention to start out
2021
with a balanced news diet download the
ground news app for free
by going to davidpakman.com ground
the link is right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that the david pakman show is
primarily sponsored by viewers and
listeners like you grab yourselves a
membership
at joinpakman.com coupon code better21
always available we talked last week
about a poll that showed
that 64 of current republicans are
willing to leave the republican party if
donald trump were to start
a third party and this
reinforced the sort of soft nature of
much of the support of the republican
party
as well as the cachet that donald trump
at least
now as we approach one month since he's
been out of office that for at least now
donald trump still has on the republican
party
uh but that is all hypothetical those
are people who
would be willing to leave the republican
party what about people that
are leaving and not because trump
starred in another party but just
because they're leaving
there's a very interesting a series of
studies many of them out of california
some out
of florida as well which show that there
are already
thousands and thousands of voters in
some counties that are leaving the
republican party
um and what they where they are going
remains a question and we're going to
talk about that in a moment
um but this seems to be a reaction to
uh the defeat of donald trump combined
with two months of lies
about the election supposedly having
been stolen from him and
of voting experts at the university of
florida
say that there are thousands and
thousands of republicans that are no
longer traditional republicans that are
no longer
registered as republicans anymore
and that while there are often changes
to party registrations
all the time and in particular after
elections that the number of republicans
leaving the party are significantly
greater
in number than the number of democrats
that are changing their registrations
they looked at san diego county in
california as well as some other uh
parts of
of the country and um it appears as
though
the january sixth trump riot was sort of
like the straw that broke the camel's
back it's unclear that
it alone is the explanation for why so
many republicans are abandoning their
party but rather
the sort of culmination to months and
really years
of a complete joke of a republican party
with donald trump at the helm at its
head
and it is believed indeed that the
abandonment of the republican party by
these folks is a sort of rejection of
trumpism more than it is of what the
republican party used to be
these folks who are leaving widely
believe to still be in line
with whatever values or ideologies
brought them in in the first place
whether it was
ronald reagan 40 years ago or whether it
was someone like
uh either of the george bush's um
or more the newt gingrich style early
90s politics that attracted people to
the republican party or folks like john
mccain and mitt romney more recent
republican nominees
whatever it was that brought them in
they still they're not
leftists they're not leaving because
they're leftists but they're leaving
as a rejection of trumpism is what it
seems to be now there's a really
important and obvious question to ask if
we want to figure out
what is or is there an electoral impact
to this which is
okay if you leave the republican party
are you still voting for republicans
unless we have reason to believe
otherwise they probably are
you can leave the republican party and
be an independent and still vote just
for republicans
and i can't imagine that many of these
folks are looking to vote for democrats
uh
at the state and local level maybe some
would stay home which would still be
help to the democratic party uh and
sadly
i believe most of these folks will be
very quick to return if indeed what
they're doing is rejecting trumpism by
leaving
as soon as the media focus gets back to
black lives matter is terrible
and joe biden's allowing immigrants into
the country and owe the debt and the
deficit and all of that
tried and true stuff that we predicted
republicans would go back to after trump
and that we're already seeing them go
back to after trump
i believe many will return to the party
and importantly i don't think many of
these folks
will opt to vote for democrats rather
than
whatever republicans they can vote for
in 2022
and in 2024 assuming donald trump is not
the nominee at that point in time
so you know you know independents who
used to be republicans that still vote
for republicans
not super interesting and it's important
to know
as a general political concept when we
talk about independence
there are some folks who uh like to
frame themselves as these enlightened
centrists that are not loyal to either
party
and sometimes they vote for republicans
or for democrats or green party or
whatever
the vast majority of independents vote
overwhelmingly for one party or the
other
and they are essentially as partisan as
most democrats or republicans they just
aren't officially affiliated with any
party
and let's not overstate the importance
of party registration alone now that
being said
uh if a lot of republicans are
abandoning the party
um if some of them are saying for the
time being i'm not going to be donating
these are things that could make a
difference the question then becomes
will democrats take advantage of it and
that
certainly remains to be seen former vice
presidential
candidate and former governor of alaska
sarah palin
a big trumpist was interviewed by good
morning britain
and it is absolutely nuts and
you know i jokingly said 10 days ago on
twitter remember when sarah palin was
the craziest person in the republican
party back in 2008
and how now she seems so moderate
compared to some of this wacky q anon
stuff
then i saw this interview from yesterday
and now i'm thinking no no sarah palin's
just as wacky as a lot of these q anon
people
let's uh look at some of some clips here
we'll dive right in first question to
sarah palin was
does trump bear responsibility for the
january 6th
riots the president told uh those who
are
attending the rally to go protest
peacefully and patriotically
and legally so no we're so these idiots
who did storm the capital um
and now they're blaming the president
for their own actions i think that's a
symptom of
a societal problem where people just
cannot take responsibility for their
stupid
and criminal acts the hilarity of sarah
palin saying
this is about people being unable to
take personal responsibility for their
actions
that's what started this entire thing
that's what got us here if on november
8th which was the day that
the media called the election for joe
biden
if on november 8th donald trump and
republicans took responsibility
and said we lost we failed on covet and
we lost or we didn't do
for whatever reason we lost and that's
it that
responsibility would have prevented all
of this
and of course after the fact in trump's
inciting of the riot as well they
are completely denying any
responsibility whatsoever but that
personal responsibility
is not what sarah palin is talking about
she says that the problem with personal
responsibility
is the people who did the rioting aren't
taking personal responsibility
then sarah palin makes the case that
listen the writers were already there
planning chaos
they weren't influenced by donald trump
at all and piers morgan points out well
hold on a second
the two months of the lie about election
fraud from november 4th
that was really the initial catalyst for
these people being
so whipped up to begin with this is why
they were even there
on january 6th it's a very good point
sarah palin doesn't like it
also you have to remember that those who
were these writers and again
they were horrible and they had it was a
horrible act
um they were there already so many of
them were they weren't
like standing in the back of the rally
um root non patriotically
a president's speech no they were they
knew what they were gonna do they were
gonna
go storm the capital and be jerks yeah
the reason they were going to sarah
the reason sarah palin they were going
to do that is because the president
ever since the result of a fair
democratic election
had perpetuated an absolute lie that
there had been widespread fraud
which has never been proven at all it
didn't exist
he whipped his mob into a frenzy he told
them to stop the steal
and as the elected officials in congress
were actually ratifying the election
he ordered them to march down to the
capital and stop the steal
and yeah some of them may have just got
the wrong memo but you know what it
sounded to me
like the president wanted to stop the
steel as he put it and stop the
democratic election
being ratified that i'm afraid is a
criminal action isn't it
why are you generalizing though and
making it sound like
it was this entire crowd that was so
excited
now this is just rich why are you
generalizing
she says well he's not generalizing 75
million people voted for trump
piers isn't talking about 75 million
people because most of them stayed home
on january 6.
thousands and thousands of people went
to the january sixth trump rally
piers also isn't talking about all of
them because some of them when the rally
was over
turned around and they went to their
cars or got on the subway and went home
where they came from
uh he is doing the opposite of
generalizing he's talking specifically
about the people who went to the capitol
and were trespassing and vandalizing and
being violent was it 500 people was it
1500 people
2 000 we're still trying to figure out
the exact number he's not generalizing
at all
and this continues and sarah palin won't
even concede that donald trump lost
and this is where it you really see the
full delusion of sarah palin
and i know some people are going to
write to me and say david she seems
unwell
she just she seems like she's not well
uh and unfortunately
this is the impression we get from a lot
of these right-wing uh loons
so i don't know that that tells us much
one way or the other about her politics
but she was asked
trump want trump didn't win right like
trump lost and she says well
i don't know take a look sarah i saw
thousands of people i'm not generalizing
we all saw the scene i watched thousands
of people
sound like it was the entire crowd no i
watched thousands of people
storming into the capital we all watched
it with our own eyes it was one of the
most
okay i'm talking about the thousands who
did and there's no question
there's no question they were whipped up
to do so because they believed their
president
who told them the election had been
stolen fraudulently stolen that was a
lie
wasn't it uh the president has been
insisting so many americans have been
insisting
that our elections are run
legally and transparently
and when there were shenanigans
obviously in um
so many of the polling areas the
president
has insisted that we look into
where all these votes had come from the
election wasn't stolen was it sarah
palin let's be honest just be clear
the election the election was won sarah
the election
the election was one let me just say
something and there are always this
sarah the election was won the election
was won
fair and square by a thumping win by joe
biden do you accept that
uh i want to see that our elections
and every polling place is run cleanly
now i was a governor
so she will not admit that in trying to
defend trump
from any blame about people storming the
capital
she's doing the exact thing that started
all of this to begin with which is she's
now been asked
twice did trump lose and she's not
answering the question and it continues
the question was do you accept
the electoral victory by jova by crazy
if you guys invited me to come on
we didn't answer that part of the
question you didn't answer my question
if you want to if you want to finish
okay
why don't you answer the questions now
i'm talking about clean elections
and i know that shenanigans do take
place in elections
as a governor i witnessed that also
and we were always having to crack down
through division of elections and the
lieutenant governor's office and he
answered the question
the democrats who are in charge of it
because for instance
we had um barack obama's right hand man
uh let's not talk about obama he hasn't
been him
sarah you can't filibuster us
now listen let's go back to the question
the question was do you accept
the joe biden okay let's go okay let's
no let's go back to let me ask you a
question
and you and you answered my question
look did joe pie go back to the first
question
did joe biden did joe fight
let me try and answer a question
absolute
hysteria it's it's incredible that there
are
layers of hysteria here that
we're unable to even get to because she
won't get through the first level of
hysteria like
allowing the question to simply uh
uh be repeated and then giving an answer
did joe biden win
here's one more attempt the rioters on
the day
of joe biden win the election
can we please finish what the topic why
did you just skip on over there because
it's about the
laws of the issue isn't it the president
who is facing impeachment
if he was solely to blame for these
criminals and they're i believe he was
to blame for the criminals but i'm
asking you
sarah palin whether you believe joe
biden won the election
well evidently he did because he's sworn
in as our president
but no one will convince me nor anyone
else with common sense
um and a sense of justice uh no one will
convince
us that there were not shenanigans going
on with the shenanigans explain to me
given that nobody has produced any facts
to prove
there was widespread forward in the
election do you have it now can you show
us can you tell me
where's the fruit spot now don't
interrupt me while i finish this point
okay listen how many
polling areas had to produce
their voter rolls and they showed that
there were
say more votes than there were voters
in certain districts where's the fraud
is that where is the single core where
is the single
where has a single court in america
upheld fraud
okay you're asking if there was fraud
i'm i'm telling you where the
shenanigans were
what about all the dead people who voted
where was that held in court i don't
know sarah we like you on this program
sarah i like how piers says he likes her
on the program i find her completely
insufferable
and corrosive to american politics he
likes her okay
more votes than people wasn't
demonstrated anywhere just because they
repeat it doesn't make it true
and then dead people voting come on it's
been so widely debunked every time it's
been investigated
dead people voting were actually a
combination of people who were
registered
but died before the election and didn't
vote being registered to vote and then
dying
and not voting isn't a crime it's not
shenanigans it's not foul play
uh clerical errors some junior senior
confusion where like a junior voted and
the vote was counted as their dad
who might have been uh dead at the time
of the election but it was still only
one vote it just counted for the wrong
person that's another thing that
happened
um and then also when uh i believe it
was
channel 4 in the uk did an investigation
about this
a lot of the people that were just
claimed to be dead
we're actually just alive and that's
happened to me remember i was featured
in a documentary about people who were
supposedly
dead and i had to put out a statement
saying i am i am very much alive right
now so
that is um these are all uh untruths
and this went on and on there are
probably about another five or six
minutes of it i won't play more
but absolutely horrifying that
sarah palin was very close to being the
vice president
of the united states and had she been
vice president she would have been as
the phrase goes
a heartbeat away from being president of
the united states
really scary stuff i'd rather her saying
crazy things in alaska
than in the white house for sure but
that doesn't make what she's saying
any less outrageous we'll have more of
this including commentary your
commentary
on the david pakman show instagram make
sure you're following us there
at david pakman show we'll take a quick
break and be right back
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world famous bonus
show every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpacman.com that's join p
a k m a n dot com if the normal prices
strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
welcome back to the david pakman show
today we're going to be speaking to john
mark hanson who's a professor in
political science at the university of
chicago we are going to talk a little
bit about
uh what would it look like to rig and or
steal an american presidential election
mark it's great to have you on thank you
it's great to be here
so okay i mean at this point i don't
think we have to rehash all of the
claims that were made between november
4th
and january 6th or january 20th or even
up until today and continue to be made
let's just get into the reality so so
maybe the audience can understand what
would go into this
could could a an american presidential
election which is really 50
state elections could it be rigged could
it be stolen how would it have to be
done if so
well i would say that it's difficult to
the point of impossible um
i think many people just don't
understand the scale of the effort that
would be involved to
actually fix a presidential election
you're not talking about
a few hundred votes you're not talking
about a few thousand votes you're
talking about tens
or even hundreds of thousands of votes
uh spread along a number of states
so there are folks who will say well you
know 80 million votes versus 75 million
or whatever you
you don't really need to flip millions
of votes you really need
for example in 2016 it was 77 000 votes
in three states
in 2020 it was depending on how you
slice it about 100 000 votes
that's very different than millions so
that presumably would make it simpler
uh simpler but not by any means simple
if you imagine what it would take to
shift a
number of votes and and bear in mind
that you don't know exactly where the
problem is going to be you don't know
exactly what the
margin you need is and you don't know
exactly where it's going to be
so you have to start months in advance
and you have to be thinking in terms of
tens of thousands of votes
and you have to be thinking about how it
is that you would
recruit tens of thousands of people to
participate in this effort
uh without uh anybody blowing a whistle
on you
okay so let me play devil's advocate
maybe you don't need to recruit tens of
thousands if you can
just get a few tech people who quote
control the voting machines
that might be a simple way and you might
only need five or six people
well that is the case however
um you still have to maintain a
conspiracy of those five or six people
um and one of the things we know is it's
very difficult to maintain conspiracy so
there are many many business frauds that
go awry
or criminal frauds or criminal
activities that go awry because
people feel the need to say something
either because they want to boast about
it
or because they have a guilty conscience
or whatever so
you would have to you would have to have
a great deal of trust in your
confederates
but even beyond that there are lots and
lots and lots of barriers have been
erected to actually manipulating the
vote in that way
there are security measures for the
technology that's used
in voting and vote counting and moreover
there's the knowledge of the um
there's the knowledge of the people who
are overseeing the voting process
and so if some county comes in all of a
sudden with ten thousand more votes than
they've ever
cast before someone might say boy that
looks kind of fishy
maybe we'll look closer at that uh there
are
so many different claims that have been
made about
mechanisms for subterfuge some of which
conflict
with each other and maybe i don't know
how much we need to necessarily get into
that but just
to talk about a few of the different
things there's as i mentioned the idea
of
simply using uh hacking skills
to change the vote tallies of
a group of voting machines we heard
stories of
so-called massive dumps of ballots
coming in in the middle of the night on
vans and
and literally just taking boxes of
ballots out which
presumably in that case the voting
machines aren't being manipulated but
someone's feeding in
a bunch of ballots there's the idea of
having
election workers look at ballots
and then disqualify only some presumably
to help one candidate and hurt the other
all of these are based on different
principles and what to me seems very
difficult would be
that you might end up with one of these
strategies
working against a different one
conflicting the coordination of such
strategies seems extraordinarily
difficult
yeah it's enormously difficult um
take take for instance the idea of a
bunch of ballasts that get dumped
so most states uh most jurisdictions in
fact allow partisan observers to ballot
counting
and so all of a sudden these ballots
come in and someone might say so where
did they come from
um how do we know that they're authentic
there should be a mark on the ballot um
there should be some kind of record
that the person at the polling place
actually
authorizes this person to vote uh or if
it's an absentee ballot it should meet
the requirements for absentee ballots
which often times include a signature
they include a valid application all
kinds of things so there are
all kinds of safeguards to prevent
ballots from being submitted
fraudulently and certainly
all kinds of safeguards to make sure
that if there are
frauds that there's a likelihood of
they're being discovered particularly on
a large scale
yeah when it comes to in-person voter
fraud uh the idea of someone
i don't even know sometimes it's not
even clear to me exactly how you would
do it you would go to multiple polling
places
or show up and claim to be a variety of
different people i mean you wouldn't be
registered in multiple places so going
to polling places as you wouldn't
wouldn't work i guess you could show up
and say
at one polling place you say you're joe
smith and at the next place you say
you say you're steve johnson and that
type of thing but it seems like
in order to flip 50 000 votes with that
strategy
you need thousands of people making it
incredibly unlikely to be able to do it
secretly
exactly exactly just think about
recruiting
such a number of people so somehow
you're going to have to
find a bunch of people who are willing
to take the risk
uh either to their freedom or to their
pocketbook or to their reputations to
participate in all of this
and you're going to have to make sure
that you don't reach anybody who has
a healthy enough conscience that they
would blow the whistle on you
when it comes to people getting caught
attempting to do these things from
looking at the brennan center for
justice's
work on this which has looked at over a
billion votes over i don't i don't know
how many years many many years
they say that this in-person voter fraud
is not only extremely rare but there is
not even a single case in which it has
come
close to actually affecting the outcome
of of a race
uh there are people who will claim maybe
cynically maybe not
that just because this brennan center
gives us these numbers it doesn't
address the number of people that are
getting away with it which simply don't
show up when you hear about oh 20 people
were caught trying to do this
how can we defeat the idea that maybe
there are lots of people not
caught doing it well again
i think the you have to kind of do the
math on it
so any kind of large-scale effort means
that the difficulties go up the costs go
up
and the risk of exposure goes up the
more people are involved in this the
more votes they're involved in this
the greater the likelihood that it's
going to be found so
yeah maybe there are people who get away
with it but there are people who get
away with it
may be affecting one or two votes you
know out of all the scrutiny that this
last election got
so far the only indictment that we've
seen for any kind of voting
irregularities was a man in pennsylvania
who voted an absentee ballot for his
mother right for donald trump
so you know that's the that's the
typical kind of thing that we see in
these cases
most cases of vote fraud or
alleged vote fraud are not even
prosecuted because it's people making
honest mistakes
right they thought that they were
registered but they weren't um or they
thought that they were eligible in this
jurisdiction but they weren't or so
forth so uh
most of these cases uh have quite
innocent explanations
what would be of all of these different
mechanisms what's the one you're most
likely to get away with
oh boy um i'm not sure that there
are that many possibilities anymore
you know back in the bad old days there
used to be a fair bit of vote fraud it
was committed both by republicans and by
democrats
um and as a result of that um
you know election officials learn
through time uh what those uh
what those frauds look like um and they
learned about how to take security
measures to make sure that those frauds
didn't occur
um and so by now with a century of
experience with
the australian ballot with the secret
ballot
we have lots and lots of of experience
in this
um and it's not like people have just
been twiddling their thumbs and saying
oh my oh my when they encounter problems
they've taken steps to avoid them in the
future when it comes to the us having
these 50 election systems plus dc i
guess you'd say
you know it's 51 election systems one
could make the argument
that um the election is less secure
because you have so many different
systems but on the other hand you could
make the argument that
having all of these systems actually
makes it more secure because in order to
really do
some kind of fraud at a big level you'd
have to figure out a way to manipulate
multiple different systems do you think
that having the 51
different systems on balance makes the
election
more or less secure that's a good
question
i think you could argue it both ways
certainly one could argue that
if you have separate systems you might
not have all jurisdictions adopting best
practices
and that would be an argument for a more
uniform system
on the other hand if it is a matter of
some kind of technical expertise
to manipulate these systems then having
a wide variety of systems means that
you have to have a greater variety of
technical expertise in order to do
anything significant
do you think that because of all of the
the smears
that we've heard over the last two three
months about the
election of 2020 there's going to be a
skepticism about the system in some
parts
among some communities that will last a
long time or is it as simple as
if in 2022 politicians don't make these
claims people will generally speaking
trust the systems again
well i think that there is now a
partisan reason not to quote unquote
trust the system
whether that actually translates into
people behaving in a different way i
think
is another question entirely there are
all these
concerns in georgia for instance in the
senate runoff that
that donald trump's casting aspersions
on the fairness of the georgia election
would mean that republicans would stay
home um why
right then they definitely lose right
right why would you do that so so um
i'm i'm skeptical that it will matter a
whole lot
what it what it does do however is to
raise the possibility of
just casting doubt on legitimacy of
every election outcome and that's a bad
thing
yeah and that uh it seemed i mean i i
there was a woman who
confronted mitt romney in an airport a
couple of weeks ago
and almost like as a reflexive thing
she said you weren't your election
wasn't even legitimate and like who who
i didn't even know the utah 2018
election
was being challenged in terms of its
legitimate legitimacy it seems it's
becoming a catch-all for i don't like
that you won
uh yeah that's right that's right um and
this has been brewing for a while it's
been a republican strategy since 2010
basically to elect more to erect more
and more and more barriers
um to the um to voting and and
particularly
to the constituencies that tend to vote
democratic um
just in order to keep one's opponents
away from the polls
right so you know this is actually
and in that respect the 2020 election
was something of an embarrassment
uh because we had uh easier access to
voting than we've ever had before in our
history
and we have a whistle clean election so
now what are they going to claim
right how how can they how can they say
well actually
things do work um and so we get a
doubling down on these fraud claims
yeah and uh in fact christopher krebs uh
who worked for donald trump
said exactly that it was fine and he was
fired and so we see
the the political nature that that it's
taking on uh we've been speaking
with professor john mark hanson who
teaches political science
at the university of chicago so great
having you on today i really appreciate
it
it's been fun thank you the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
slash david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
we're learning more and more about the
absolute fury that overtook donald trump
after seeing
one of his two impeachment attorneys
yesterday bruce castor
aimlessly uh wander
through his personal background the
political preferences of his parents
praise of senators a discussion of uh
pre-revolutionary war british law really
everything but the subject matter of the
impeachment during his opening
statements yesterday which lasted about
50 minutes or rather not opening
statements the opening to
the day one proceedings to determine
whether the senate has the jurisdiction
to try a president that is no longer
in office as we talked about yesterday
the senate voted 56-44 that yes
they can have the impeachment trial
there's a report from
cnn that donald trump was quote deeply
unhappy with the performance of bruce
castor
multiple sources familiar with trump's
reaction said to cnn that trump was
borderline screaming
as uh bruce castor uh was failing
uh humiliatingly embarrassingly on uh
global television yesterday um and
uh particularly was upset that those
opening remarks from bruce castor
were rambling trump's team also
was reportedly confused uh about the
last minute decision to swap the order
of his defense
caster who did the 50 minutes of
rambling first
was actually scheduled to speak after
david shone
and people around trump thought that
this new idea of having bruce castor go
first wasn't a particularly strong idea
now of course they were right how much
of it is hindsight bias i don't know
uh but they say that donald trump was
particularly upset
when the first thing bruce castor said
when he got up there was
the house managers the prosecution did a
really great job
and of course it was true uh it was true
that they did a good job but it's not
typically what you want your defense
counsel to be
admitting the new york times also had a
report in which they said that caster
getting up there and praising the
impeachment managers was not
well received by donald trump and they
reported that
uh some of trump's uh legal team were
actually surprised that there would be
raw video shown from the january 6th
riots
this to me you know we said when your
own legal team misspells united states
as united states that should be a signal
that maybe they're not playing with a
full deck when it comes to
preparation and democrats had been
saying for days
we are going to show video of the riots
uh trump's defenders were saying well
trump's lawyers are going to show videos
at some point of democrats calling for
violence
okay well so everybody knows what to
expect
but reportedly trump's legal team was
surprised that there was video of the
riots
shown oh i sort of half jokingly five
percent jokingly
said during the uh proceedings yesterday
does bruce castor get fired today by
donald trump apparently
it's actually something trump is
considering the daily beast was told by
a source familiar with what was going on
that donald trump is considering pulling
bruce castor from the legal team
altogether which would put everything on
uh in particular on david shone which
would be a uh
a lot of work to say the least as far as
the schedule goes the impeachment trial
is expected
to go uh through the week and into next
week there are going to be
um eight hours of presentations from the
house managers eight hours of
presentations from trump's defense
council
there will then be it's either four
hours total or four hours
per party of questions for the
uh impeachment managers and defense
counsel and then there will also be
closing statements so i'm expecting at
least into monday or tuesday although
these things change so quickly that
that the plan the plan may change
relatively soon trump
furious with bruce castor understandable
why
why can't trump just get people who are
adequately prepared to represent him in
a way that's not embarrassing maybe it's
because a lot of lawyers know
they're probably not going to get paid
by trump since he stiffs people on legal
bills
i don't really know the answer but it
just will not stop um
we had another yesterday in the
uh in the rush to get this first day
of trump's second impeachment trial um
out live on all of our platforms i did
not cover
the white house press briefing with
press secretary
jen saki and yes i will address my
pronunciation of saki um
in the voicemail segment today and
reporters
just will not stop asking really dumb
questions here is a reporter asking jen
saki does joe biden plan on hanging up a
painting
of donald trump in the white house
of course donald trump not hanging a
painting of obama as is often done of
the prior
president in the midst of everything
that's going on in week three of joe
biden's administration
jen saki asked what about joe biden's
view on a trump
painting in the white house um
president trump former president trump
he broke tradition by not having
his predecessor have a portrait hanged
up here
that as far as i'm saying that was
something that was considered totally
the normal thing to do
will president biden be inviting his
predecessor to hang up a portrait
somewhere
and will he get the obamas back in to
finally get their you know their
ceremony
i have no portrait revealings or
portrait plans or portrait events to
preview for you
but i have not been given any indication
that we would break with tradition in
that regard
so not a major issue as you can imagine
i really don't know what's up with some
of these questions it's not completely
clear to me because they're not
necessarily coming from
all from reporters with with bad
reputations or from whom
we would expect this i mean peter ducey
yes
we know what he's trying to do and get
sound bites for right-wing media but
some of these are not reporters that
have particularly
bad reputations or or are known to have
bad intentions but we these these
questions simply will not stop now
here's a bonus clip i mentioned peter
ducey
uh peter ducey asking a question this is
just unbelievable
irony is dead peter ducey asked about
conflicts of interest for joe biden you
really can't make this up uh
joe biden's um son-in-law
was advising biden on vaccine response
at some earlier point
here is peter ducey continuing to try to
make a name for himself with supposedly
tough questions of jen
saki and he brings this up take a listen
quick one on conflicts of interest and
some reporting that's been done
by our colleagues at other networks the
president's son-in-law
dr howard crying was advising candidate
biden
on kobe 19 response while he was
investing
in companies involved with the cobia 19
response through
his company startup health dr crying has
been
at the white house since the
inauguration is he still
advising the president on copenhagen
response well dr crine is his son-in-law
um the president there are questions
about a potential well and i think he
was here because the president was
inaugurated recently which is
understandable the president has made
clear that there will be an
absolute wall between him and any
businesses connected with his
family members and as he reiterated just
last week
no family member is going to have an
office in the white house or be involved
in any government policy making
that applies to his son-in-law and
applies to every single member of his
family
this guy was there for the inauguration
he's not working for the white house
how can they pretend to care about
conflicts of interest
now we just learned jared and ivanka
in positions not confirmed by the senate
nor
elected by the people were working in
the white house
and made between 200 and 600 million
dollars
while working at the white house for
those four years
now sadly we expected this and
unfortunately it does work on a lot of
people
millions of trump supporters who never
cared about conflicts of interest for
the last four years
will fixate on this stuff and in that
sense it's not stupid for fox news to do
it
for their audience they look like
complete
fools to most of the world and the
country
but for much of their audience this is
how they generate
narratives and create agendas but what
about what about this what about this
vaccine advice
where were you when ivanka was making
millions from
handbags and working for trump and
kellyanne conway was promoting the
handbags on fox news where were you then
well they were nowhere because they
didn't care
and it's not about principle it's merely
about what can we say to try to attack
joe biden and unfortunately
for the low information fox news
audience the oan types the news max
types
this may well be compelling and it's how
you generate narrative
hey so i i've been i guess struggling
with how to pronounce the name of joe
biden's white house press secretary
and i got yet another voicemail
admonishing me about it remember our
voicemail number is 219
to david p take a listen
hello david this is a fan my name is sue
and i mean this in the most kindly way
since you will be pronouncing
the white house press secretary's name
hundreds of times
i would suggest that you pronounce it
correctly yes it's
jen saki with a a
a short no yes a soft a instead of
instead of saki jen saki bye bye
so i at the beginning i would say jen
saki and then a few people wrote to me
and said david it's sake
so i switched to saki and then over the
weekend i got a dozen emails saying
david it's saki
and now i'm being told it's saki i am
going to pronounce it
saki and the reason why is that gen saki
recently did an interview
with a longtime friend of hers and he
pronounced it saki
i assume he knows how it's said so i'm
going to be pronouncing it jensaki
until someone explains to me a good
reason why i should reverse course once
again
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we've got resignations
we've got black history month drama in
utah schools
we've got uh more statements about the
lab hypothesis of the coronavirus all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show
get instant access by signing up at
joinpacman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
unbiased news is a myth ground news is a
news comparison platform that empowers
you to see how the political biases of
different sources
are influencing the news you read
download the ground news app for free
at davidpakman.com ground